Is this a picture of Mohammed?
Something?
Woke me up at 5:30 this morning.
Maybe it was my conscience.
Maybe it was God.
Take your pick.
I'll go for conscience.
In any case this week,
Canada's government is going to consider
an anti Islamophobia emotion.
Mon.
Oh,
three in parliament.
BefOre that happens,
I have some things to say.
Moses was a murderer.
Christ was a bastard,
and mohammed
mohammed was a.
Mohammed was a.
Muhammad was a
holy man who's every word and action was
correct.
I asked muslims worldwide.
Can I say anything else?
On the week canada's government is going
to discuss anti islamophobia.
Emotion am one.
Oh,
three in parliament.
I asked muslims worldwide.
Can I say anything else?
I asked muslims in the west.
I asked muslims in Canada.
Can I say anything else?
I asked you a sponsor of [inaudible] in
Canada.
Can I say anything else?
Is this a picture of mohammed?
Where do I cross the line?
This is a picture of christ.
This is a picture of mo.
This is a picture of a moBile.
This is a picture of moses.
This is a picture of mole.
this is a picture of mole.
Is this a picture of mohammed?
This might be a picture of mohammed.
Did I cross the line?
When do I become solomon rushdie?
I'm a westerner.
I am solomon rushdie.
Your colleague.
Are you solomon rushdie?
When do I become a danish cartoonist?
I'm a westerner.
I am a danish cartoonist.
It
are you a danish cartoonist?
When do I become charlie hebdo?
I'm a westerner.
I can criticize so that things can
improve
so that we're not trapped in the dead
past so that we're not trapped in the
embrace of the corpses of the past.
I am charlie hebdo it.
Kelly.
Are you charlie hebdo?
Which side are you on?
Every westerners.
Solomon rushdie.
Every westerner is a danish cartoonist.
Every westerners.
Charlie hebdo.
Who is it?
When push comes to shove,
as It will this week,
where is she going to scanned muslims of
the world on the week of anti
islamophobia motion?
One hundred three in Canada,
muslims of the west on the week of anti
islamophobia emotion.
One.
Oh,
three in Canada,
muslims of Canada on the week of anti.
Islamophobia.
Motion one.
Oh,
three in Canada.
Eager khaleed of Canada.
Who sponsored the motion after the
murders in quebec city
on the week of anti islamophobia motion
one.
Oh,
three in Canada.
Can I say this is a picture of the
prophet mohammed?
Because if I can't,
it's not islamophobia.
Is this a picture of mohammed?
Is this a picture of mohammed.